This is like the beginning of the Grudge dude
Holy s**t
Wait who is that?
Probably what I would call like one of the coolest vintage anamorphic looks you can get on a budget
*screams*
*destruction*
God
*laughs*
So Nick tell me about the ghost
I was like laying in bed it was about 3am, I hear like these loud footsteps above me
Just like that like...
*Creaking*
But like, directional.
Like someone's walking-it sounded like someone was straight up walking right above my bed.
So I was like "Ok, someone's on my roof"
Before I moved there, I lived in an apartment under people, I know
I was so used to the sound of like *Imitating Creaking Noises*
And I had my friend, Nick, crashing on my couch.
I go out there in the morning and he's like
"Dude your neighbors were, like, they were really loud"
I don't have any neighbors.
D**n, that's creepy.
So, he heard it too.
I call my landlord, like "Did you have anything scheduled"
"Or is there even access to the roof"
He's like "Well actually, there's a 3 foot to 4 foot crawl space under the roof in-between your room and the roof"
"So, if you were to hear something, it would have been in the crawl space"
*unintelligible*
There's no easy way for someone to get up there without making a lot of noise, and they'd need a ladder
What if they were already up there What if they've been up there
I've looked thoroughly there's no access point from my apartment and the crawl space
You don't know what happens until you go up to the attic
*unintelligible*
floorboards above my beds or something dude
Actually that's preety bad
We just go there and 3 2 1 turn all the lights
Someone's gonna be up there
*GAAH*
You turn on the lights dude and
Gaaah
*signs of disgust*
What kind of equipment do we bring
Remember when i mentioned i had that ladder
I brought it last December and never took it out of the box
This is the best case scenario
Like we have a ladder thats brand new
*drinking*
no
Its a telescoping ladder
*clicking*
Hey whats up Sam
We could absolutely use this
This is great
Can i try it
sure
There's someone in your attic
Just admit there's someone in your attic and were gonna find him tonight
there gonna be like You got the same ladder as me